Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you.
It's 9:25 PM here.
This is a really weird podcast.
I'm going to be taping this on my iPhone.
I'm probably going to do half of it and then I'm going to head out.
It's my last night in Scotland.
I,
my last night just Portland.
I had a fucking blast,
but I gotta tell you met Jesus Christ to have to spend in three fucking days in
Scotland,
Scotland ball go by bottle wall,
um,
the apart five bottle of warm,
I fucking,
I just want to be dry it,
it's just rained essentially nonstop and it didn't even have the fucking decency
to just rain.
It's just been slowly,
just fucking spitting in your face.
And I finally was talking to this cab driver on the way over and he was just
going,
I was like,
does it always rain during the summer over here?
Cause there's summer,
there's no summer in Scotland.
Summer in Scotland is you go to Turkey,
Greece or Spain or some shit like that.
He just basically saying,
I guess the sun never fucking shines here,
you know,
is it any wonder why everybody is so God damn funny up here.
Um,
I,
oh man,
I had such great shows and one of the,
another really weird venue.
I didn't even know what the fuck it was.
It took me like to my third show to realize it was a gymnasium.
I finally saw a backboard like a basketball rim,
you know,
with the glass and it was just sort of cranked up against the ceiling.
And um,
I dunno,
just really like,
it's weird.
It was like totally fucking bizarre,
but some of the best shows I've had on the tour and just really had a great
time.
Scottish people are fucking hilarious.
So even when people yelled out half the time they said Shit funnier than what I
was talking about.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
trying to pack up here.
Oh man,
I packed perfectly on this fucking tour.
I absolutely fucking crushed it all they have.
I'm going to be over in Europe tier for 23 fucking days.
I have a little bitchy ass stewardess little wheely thing.
And a backpack and that's it.
You know why?
Cause I fucking traveled and I've done the thing where you bring light fucking
five pairs of tee shirts,
three different fucking workout things.
Sweatpants.
Oh,
oh what if,
what if we go ballroom dancing?
What if another night we go to a bull fight?
Um,
you know what if for some reason we do some jousting right and you just pack
every stupid ass fucking outfit and you know what happens?
You like five days into your fucking trip and you realize that you've worn the
same t shirt every single day and you know what?
No one gives a shit and there's nothing worse then is because then you start
buying shit over there.
There's no fucking room and you just looking at all these fucking tee shirts and
all these sweatpants and these stupid fancy hats,
whatever the fuck it is you're into that you're brought and you never wore.
I actually still packed too much shit.
There's a,
there's a,
I got two great tee shirts.
I've yet to use them.
You have to fucking use them.
No one knows you out here.
No one gives a shit you think is going to walk by,
you know,
walk by someone and they'd be like,
oh,
that's that fucking tourist came by yesterday wearing the same t shirt.
You know,
it's not high school.
Nobody knows who the fuck you are.
Anybody can blow anybody away.
Um,
so uh,
yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
I packed like an absolute champ and now,
now I'm home.
I'm going to the motherland.
Now I'm going to Germany where uh,
I've never really done a background check on me,
but I just looked at a little bit of the family tree.
I got a lot of German last names in the tree,
so I know I got a significant amount of fucking Germans letting me,
dude,
I got to give it up to the Scots.
You know,
a lot of countries you go to,
their money just looks fake and stupid.
The fucking Scott's got great currency.
These coins actually seem like they're worth something and they got a wait to
them.
You know,
they got some good designs on them.
Um,
plus it always helps.
So people from Scotland talk like the pirates,
you know,
just gives a of some sort of level of like,
I dunno,
credibility to anything that the fucking saying.
I'm sure the audio is a little fucked up and literally packing right now as I'm
talking to you,
I'm going to try to knock half of this out before I get outta here.
But um,
tonight I actually had my first night off,
you know,
in 10 days.
I did 13 shows in the last 10 days and I was doing at least an hour and a half
every night for the most part except the first show here.
Um,
they told me to only do an hour,
but after that,
every other one I tried to do like a buck 15.
So I've done,
I dunno,
somewhere between 23 and 25 hours of stand up.
And it was really nice to have a,
a,
a day off.
But,
um,
I actually went out tonight and I saw the great time he Tiernan add,
uh,
this place called the gilded balloon and he's an absolute legend in Ireland,
Irish guy,
absolute legend there all through Ireland,
all through fucking Great Britain and into Europe.
And uh,
it was great,
man.
It was fun to be an audience member just sitting there watching an absolute
master up there,
storyteller and all that stuff.
Man,
it was so cool.
And um,
I just got to hang out and join,
but you were fucking sucks.
The number one fucking thing that I cannot stand about going to two alive to
anything where you got to have these rows of chairs.
I just got this perfect seat in the back,
right.
No problem.
There's like one row behind me.
I deliberately sat in the back,
you know,
cause I want to get the whole thing.
I want to watch him do his thing.
I want to see the crowd react.
I want to see,
you know,
I just,
I just want to take the whole thing in,
right.
And uh,
I'm sitting there in this right before the fucking show starts.
Just like every time you go to a movie like I'll thank God,
no one arounds talking to him,
he's talking right.
And then the fucking loud count comes walking in right before the lights go down
to show the coming attractions.
Right.
Same thing happened.
And uh,
that Tommy show,
everything was great.
I'm chilling out and then I never really got a good look at this guy,
but this guy just sounded like the biggest mouth breathing moron ever.
He sounded like his diet was horrible.
They just drank in boost.
He was like having problems just breathing.
And then when he laughed,
you could just sounded do,
you could just tell he was dumb.
He just sitting there going,
yeah,
then you go
the whole fucking time.
And then when he would,
if he would inhale like too much like that,
then he would cough and I would feel the wind on the back of my neck like every
third or fourth cough.
So now I am totally like lean forward because you know,
it's Tommy show,
it's fucking sold out and I got to lean forward like,
like I dunno what,
like I'm playing catcher or some shit and then I got to kind of look up so my
neck is fucking killing me.
I can't lean back.
And the guy,
it took every,
every skill that I have of blocking people out,
which my skills are terrible to try to make this guy not ruin the show.
Fortunately,
Tommy was so fucking funny.
I was still able to enjoy it,
but the guy behind me was so annoying me that even when he would laugh because
he had such a dumb laugh.
I'm like,
this,
you didn't fucking get what Tom was saying,
that he's too fucking brilliant.
Yeah.
That for a fucking hour it was like a Mel blanc voice.
Um,
you know,
which way you did go.
That's what it reminded me of.
Is it still fucking recording or did it turn off?
All right,
good.
well I've knocked down like seven minutes of it.
Um,
there's a very,
a very important man in town right now is a teen idol sensation from the Urbine
Anthony Program.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go to a local bar,
have a couple of SAS Barilla's with them,
see how his festival,
when I'm wearing my action slacks that I bought,
I know they're not literally called action slacks,
but I don't give a shit.
These things are,
you know,
anytime you have on pants that look like they could go with the suit,
but you could also do yoga in them.
Those are fucking action slacks.
I don't care how cool they make them now.
You know,
I don't care what NBA player fucking dances around with them doing all the
tricks with the ball and then hits a fucking three pointer.
You know,
I forget who makes these things.
It's the one that has the h on it,
the Hardcastle and McCormick,
what do they call it,
under armor?
You know,
I don't know.
He's always trying to have a bad ass name for this ship.
So anyways,
um,
Cuda Scotland,
thank you to do the French festival and everybody that,
that,
uh,
that came out.
Uh,
and thank you to everybody in Amsterdam that I talk about Amsterdam.
You have the day I think I did on the pocket and on the,
yeah,
I did.
Oh I also forgot to mention,
I went up to,
uh,
I went up to af say today,
which is this hike where you get a 360 degrees view panoramic view of I'm amber
and I have the fuck you supposed to say.
And I suppose to say Berg.
Evidently the locals get annoyed and on a clear day,
which I don't know that they even have here,
um,
you can,
uh,
you can see all the way to Glasgow,
which I performed there a couple of times.
So,
um,
I went over there and I was gonna meet fucking Derosa and Ari Shaffir,
but you know,
I couldn't figure out where the fuck they were adding.
Of course it was raining,
so I was just like,
I'll just meet you guys up top.
You know,
cause it's like all these different ways in.
And I climbed up this fucking thing.
It's hilarious.
There's just no signs telling you where to go.
It's this giant fucking thing.
And it's just,
if you find it,
you find it.
They don't give a fuck.
Half of it was these,
these rocks,
these lava rocks that I swear to go on any one of them,
any one of them,
if you slipped and fell,
if you hit it,
you shattered your elbow or fractured your fucking skull.
There was no railings.
There was no signs.
Watch your step.
There was just like,
yeah man,
you know,
just keep walking up the hill.
Eventually you'll get to the highest one and you'll know where the fuck you're
supposed to go.
There's just a bunch of tourists.
Like,
is it up that way or did,
did we go the wrong way?
You know?
And um,
it was fucking pouring down raining.
Nobody gives,
gave a shit,
no concern of a lawsuit.
It was funny,
like reminded me when I was a kid,
when picked my right before everybody got sue happy in my country and uh,
um,
ended up getting all the way up to the top and I,
you know,
I don't have a raincoat because I'm a man,
or I probably shouldn't even say that.
I guess if I was a real man,
I would've bought one.
Would address the fact that you need a coat for when it rains.
Specifically a raincoat.
But I've never been able to get myself one because they just always,
I dunno,
I just,
I just remember as a kid,
if you had a fucking rain cold plas,
like third grade,
you just,
it just meant it could you,
could you please beat the shit out of me?
No one had a fucking rain coat.
Right.
You didn't,
you just fucking,
I used to a bit about that.
Puts your shoulder
zap.
That was it.
Right.
So I was up there with this,
I dunno,
I dunno what the material was,
but it,
it,
it fucking totally lost the battle with water.
And I got all the way up to the top and of course the wind is whipping around
and I'm waiting for Ari and Derosa to show up from whatever side of the fucking
hill they were coming up.
But uh,
you know,
I was thinking like,
all right,
Ari is in good shape.
You know,
I know he's done some MMA stuff.
I don't think he's going to be the problem.
I don't think he's the,
he's the wheel that's slow in that wagon down.
I know it was to Rosa.
He was probably fucking making that face.
He always makes.
And I was just standing up there,
I gave him like five minutes and I was just like,
fuck this,
I don't see them anywhere.
And uh,
ended up walking down,
went this different way and I had on like new balance sneakers,
you know,
the Steve job ones,
which are people was giving me shit going,
you know,
those are old white guys.
Sneakers,
like SNL did a,
did a whole sketch talking about how those are old white guys,
sneakers and um,
you know,
it's like,
well,
I'm an old white guy
so I will wear these sneakers.
They were not good for the slippery love or rocks or whatever the fuck they are
up on a Arthur's seat.
And uh,
this fucking cunt was coming down behind me and he had like the climate boots on
and shit and he's like breathing down my neck.
And I was feeling the same
kind of stress I feel anytime I go out to play around a golf,
which I never do because I hate that sport.
And one of the things they hate the most about it is the stress of the people
behind you.
They're always better than you and you just feel like a fucking asshole.
Like you're holding them up.
I always tell people to play through.
It was that exact same level having anxiety,
except you just got to throw in the fact that you could possibly fracture your
skull.
Um,
so I finally had the guy go around me and it was,
it was
definitely a relief.
Hang on a second here.
I got a text to Rosa and let them know that I'm gonna meet him at that bar.
Hang on.
So anyways,
I made it down without hurting myself and I was already like,
had knee his voice in my head thinking like if I fall down and I fucking break
my elbow Assam Shit,
I'm never going to hear the end of this.
Cause she told me not to do it.
She's like,
you've been working too hard.
Yeah.
You know,
you got a cold.
You're,
you're being an idiot.
Don't go up there,
you're going to fall down and blah,
blah,
blah.
And it's just like,
well you stopped fucking Jinxing me.
You ever hear you attract what you fear?
That's what you're doing right now.
Fucking leave me alone.
And uh,
so of course I don't listen to her.
This is the thing about being a married guy.
You can't listen to your wife because when you do,
there's a party and the dyes and side,
you know,
and then when ends up happening is,
is then you lose your spirit and the light in your eye goes up.
And after the fucking person who blew it out,
that person actually has the nerve to then look at you and,
and,
and like not like you anymore because they look at you like you quit.
It's fucking nuts.
I don't know if that's true,
but,
uh,
I just said it so I'm going to go with it.
I think that that's what they do is like subconsciously,
um,
I don't know why I would say that.
Anyways.
Um,
thank you for all the tweets.
By the way,
the fellow supercar lovers out there,
then joy,
um,
those clips that I sent you of those fucking insane cars that the,
uh,
those Saudi Arabian kids in their twenties flyover into.
You know,
I was thinking about that too.
There's no fucking way you can fly a Lamborghini from Saudi Arabia to London for
20 grand.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
There's no fucking way and less,
well,
maybe this is what it is.
Maybe because the whole fucking thing is filled up and the charging everybody 20
grand that you get,
like the discount price.
I'm just going by,
you know,
I dunno.
You mean if you rent a decent fucking car,
right?
If you were in such a stupid analogy,
but if you rented decent fucking car,
right?
How much money that costs you to just fucking rent it for like the week?
That's a bad analogy.
I just,
I know there's no fucking way.
There's no way they're only going to charge a 20 grand.
I wouldn't build the fuel alone,
the fucking fuel alone.
Do you know when I,
when I fly,
uh,
when I rent a helicopter,
cost me 300 bucks to rent a helicopter.
That's why I don't do it that often.
It's not a fucking cheap thing and I'm just fucking,
you know,
going to fly it for an hour.
These guys are flying it all.
There's no fucking way.
It's 20 grand.
I Dunno.
Do you realize the arrogant level that I have that I actually think that I know
what it costs to fly Lamborghini from the Middle East to Great Britain?
How would I possibly know that?
I have no fucking idea,
but I'm watching those kids zipping around in those cars made me uh,
go on a youtube and I was watching a ton of clips of a,
you know,
those cars versus each other.
All these tests,
you know,
test drives and reviews in all of that.
I got to tell you something,
man,
there's a lot of fucking jerk offs out there that have these fucking cars.
There was this one kid,
it's just like,
I mean you would think that this guy was into like some comic con shit and he's
just like,
you know,
we still up youtube,
they always have that.
Is there anything worse when you just want to find the clip and then you get
sucked into somebodies fucking stupid TV show on Youtube,
you know?
Okay guys.
So here's the deal.
This guy has a Lamborghini.
It's like,
I know you fucking cunt.
I don't need you to tell me about it.
Somebody told me about it,
which is why I'm on here looking for this shit.
Sorry,
not yell.
And the way I usually do that,
just the people next to,
I have a little kid,
so I'm trying not to scream too loud here.
Um,
that's my number one fucking thing.
I cannot stand anything else about youtube.
I fucking love,
you know,
but I hate how they have that.
Like it'll be like a,
like whatever you want to fucking watch.
Like whatever the latest thing.
What's the latest thing that happened?
I will say that swimmer there right now,
the Bong head guy,
right with the fucking,
uh,
you know the 20 foot body there,
right?
He was given that guy that death stare.
I saw a clip.
It's like,
so and so give so and so the fucking death stare.
So what do you think I want to watch?
I want to see this guy give the guy that
death stare and every fucking thing I hit on youtube.
Youtube.
Okay.
So as we all know,
the swimmers and like act out swimming and they're trying to be all like fucking
interesting and stepping towards the camera and coming back.
It's just like,
you fucking Mano.
Browde can't just show me the fucking clip,
you know?
And then what the worst thing is,
is once the clips out there,
then every count out there,
then it has to do some fucking remix of it.
And they think it's going to be fucking hilarious.
And some of them are,
but 90% of them stink.
You know?
I don't know.
Do you guys see that?
You'd ever see the remix of the,
uh,
the Tourette's syndrome guy who totally didn't have Tourette's?
He was just acting,
I think,
but he was still funny.
Um,
somebody sent me that one on Facebook.
That one was funny.
I'll say that.
I enjoyed that one.
Sorry.
From a little fucking commodity.
Hey Man,
I'm fucking,
this weather's really,
yeah,
it's really getting to me.
So,
um,
I don't know what to expect tomorrow when I go to Germany,
but,
uh,
I'm going to a Cologne,
Germany,
not Munich,
not Berlin.
I'm basically going to the Worcester,
Massachusetts of Germany,
as far as I can tell.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're going to California,
you know,
you're not going to La,
you're not going to San Francisco.
I feel like I'm going to the Sacramento of Germany.
I have no fucking idea.
And,
but this is what I do.
I'm not going to look it up.
I'm not going to look at the pictures.
I'm not going to do anything.
I'm just going to shit on them.
And then tomorrow I'll start my show of probably getting heckles from people
going.
Actually,
we're a number one in commerce.
Um,
this is some of the most expensive real estate in the country.
I just can't imagine,
you know,
it's so fucking incredible is after I do Cologne,
I'm going to drive over to Antwerp,
Belgium.
And as far as I know,
I'm going to be passing through with a battle of the bulge was in,
uh,
in World War II.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno.
It's like that's it.
I don't know.
I guess just people live over there.
I don't know if they,
if the,
the weight of where they live really hit some just cause they're there.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like here in Scotland,
there's all these fucking touristy shops.
We can buy a fucking kilt and a bunch of Plaid Shit,
you know?
But if you,
if you look at the people who live here,
none of them wearing that shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's the to whatever you're known for.
They're sick of it.
I've been going around here trying to get authentic fucking Scottish cuisine and
I've,
there's more goddamn places to get Italian.
You can get falafels like it's anything but Scottish food.
Yeah.
They're like,
dude,
we grew up on this shit.
We don't want to eat it.
Okay.
And I don't want to dress up wearing that shit unless some playing a fucking bag
pipe or I'm doing a Goddamn Mel Gibson movie,
the granted,
I don't know if that's fucking true,
but I don't know.
W W w what do you want from me?
I go to countries for like 20 minutes and then I form opinions with without
reading shit.
You know,
it's what I do.
It's the charm of my podcast.
I like to think,
um,
where we are.
What time is it?
Nine 47.
Ah,
God,
I gotta go,
I gotta go meet to Rosa.
Um,
all right,
I'm going to head out.
If I get back at a reasonable time,
I will do the last nine minutes of this.
I don't know why I have to tell you that because I'm just going to hit stop and
then I'll just send up,
splicing them together.
MMM.
Yeah,
that's it.
All right,
so I'll be back with the magic of technology.
I will be back in like two seconds.
God knows what state of mind I'll be in.
All right,
I'm back.
Here we go.
The magic of technology.
Um,
what are we doing here?
We're doing some advertising there.
All right.
Luke crate.
Gimme the loot loot crate with loot crate.
You know what you get?
You get collectibles,
apparel and more from your favorite pop culture franchises delivered right to
your fucking into every single month.
What are we talking about?
We're talking to new t shirt and every crate figures,
comics,
stuff for your kitchen.
A wide stuff to prevent you from getting fucking late ever,
ever in your life.
Stuff for your kitchen.
A wide range of exclusive items she can't get anywhere else from fan favorite
franchises like Harry Potter,
Marvel Comics,
fallout four,
it's star wars.
He can almost hear the high heels running in the other direction and so much
more.
And uh,
you can get all this for less than $20 a month.
Well,
how much more would that shit cost,
right?
Loot crate come geek out with us.
Loot crate is a monthly subscription box service for epic Geek and Gamer items
and pop culture gear do,
they should send you a lube to fucking jerk off with two for less than $20 a
month,
you get 68 items.
That includes licensed gear,
apparel,
collectibles,
unique,
one of a kind items and more.
They kind of already said that.
Then they all right.
You have until the 19th of August at 9:00 PM to subscribe and received that
month's crate.
Excuse me.
And uh,
when the cutoff happens,
that's it.
It's over.
You never going to get that aqua man doll again.
Uh,
make sure to head over to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter the
code bird to save $3 off a new subscription August messaging.
Here we go,
uh,
from bad guys doing good things for the wrong person to good guys with
questionable tactics.
August is the purse that sounds like one of them has herpes.
August is the perfect time to explore the,
uh,
the anti hero a walk,
the hero slash villain line with this 100% exclusive collection of items from DC
comics,
Archer dark horse and kill bill that includes two collectibles and a wearable.
And of course,
our monthly tee shirt.
And don't forget the pin.
All right.
Oh,
here's another one.
one of our,
one of our favorites club.
Debbie.
Everybody clapped.
Jvs Shit avoid from my brother down there in Florida.
Now looks to you.
Nobody likes Trump.
Uh,
club.
Debbie club was my flyer.
I can't tell.
Fills up my Dick's getting cold.
Club w delivers wine straight to your door.
They send you wine that is personalized to your palate slash tastes through a
pallet quiz.
Their recommendations become even more personalized with every bottle.
Your rate clubbed.
Debbie,
my hair's real.
It's not a wig.
A works with top wine makers and growers from around the world directly to make
all of their wine and their own wine.
Sorry.
You choose the type and the quantity of the bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee.
Ooh,
in a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Uh,
there are 13 [inaudible] bottles.
Bottles would normally retail for $20.
Right now club Debbie still looking for them.
Weapons of mass destruction is offering listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to club Debbie had.com/bar and it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
You guys all hate that.
It's a club.
Debbie Played Ping ponged in the Vietnam War.
He came.
He uniform will actually pay for your shipping for orders of four bottles or
more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club W.
Dot com slash burn to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's clubbed.
Debbie,
I was named after my dad.com/burr.
Uh,
Jesus,
oh,
it's our old fucking friends here.
I got a lot of reads today.
Maybe we go boop,
boop,
me undies me undies.
Where enough fucking killed.
Bodu doot doot me undies me undies.
There's no fucking God damn guilt when you were in Scotland and it rains every
day,
you go walk around and you say,
hey,
my balls are dry because it my undies,
I lift up my fucking skirt.
Oh yeah.
Who wants to play the bagpipes?
No one.
All right,
me undies.
Uh,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spent almost 24 hours a day in your underwear unless you're Matthew
mcconaughey.
And then it's like,
I don't think he wears underwear.
It does it.
He's too busy running down the beach with those fucking leaves in his hands.
Uh,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothing,
your underwear's probably boring.
Well,
me undies is here to change that.
Some reason they can't handle the fact that you fucking underwear just looks at
regular underwear.
Uh,
every pair of me undies is made of a sustainable source.
Modal,
modal,
a fabric.
That's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies.
But once you try them on,
you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
That always bugs me.
It says nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies yet I have to
continue fucking reading them describing this shit for another three minutes.
Either you can describe it or you can't me undies.
What's with all the copy?
Um,
I love when people say that I don't have this like no words can describe.
Well then shut up and just shut the fuck up.
Alright.
Just stare straight ahead and finish your drink,
right?
You can't.
All right.
If you don't,
the first pair of me undies,
they're free.
No questions asked me.
Andy's is to test dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear.
Which statement do you need to make other than my Dick won't pop out when I walk
across the front of the bed,
over to the bathroom.
Uh,
whether anyone could see them or not.
Remember,
superman shipping is free in the United States and Canada.
And you could save up to $8 a pair with me undies subscription plan.
Sorry.
Still tired from last night.
Get to subscription or a or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash birth for 20% off your first order.
Hey,
you only start com slash for burp.
Sorry.
Oh,
here they are.
what time is it everybody?
It's time for MVMT watches.
You know,
when you're,
when you're in your early twenties and thirties,
money can be tight to keep doing drugs.
It'll have the same thing will happen in your forties and 50s.
And then in your sixties,
you know,
you'll be sleeping outside.
Um,
if you're not careful,
dressy well could quickly drag your bag.
Why am I yawning so much?
Kind of a nice night's sleep.
Uh,
like spending $400 to $500 on a department store.
Watch is some brands out there charging insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go up,
it's still have money to buy him or her a drink.
I love the political correctness of that.
Oh yeah.
Because so many women are going up buying guys drinks.
Close your eyes and even try and imagine what the fuck that looks like.
You know,
I,
I've never seen that in my life and all my fucking years of going out there
trying to be nice to these fucking who was,
I think maybe two or three women have ever bought me a drink.
You know,
I've bought plenty of women at drink,
plenty of fucking women to drink.
You know,
Jesus Christ is a line around the fucking block.
And you know,
did,
did they,
did they fucking pay me back?
I don't think they did.
The one that you can't afford a watch,
right?
Checkout Movement,
watches.com I've,
I've seen them before and these watches are sharp.
I hate when they do that shit.
I haven't seen it before.
You fucking send it to me.
I never saw him before that.
All right.
The Nice,
they're of quality,
but don't put words in my mouth.
All right,
you fucking time traveling,
coach.
All right.
Originally funded two broke college kids.
Movement watch has cut out the middleman and they're big brand retail markups.
In order to give you a stylist,
watch for an affordable price movement watches start at just $95 a watch with
department store quality for a fraction of the price.
This sleek,
Ooh,
they're minimalist.
They're minimalist.
Amar twist on a classic style honey movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you.
So join more than 1 million social media media followers and get a movement.
Watch today.
Go to MVMT watches.com/ [inaudible] and they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase.
MVMT watches.com/burr.
All right,
and how many fucking more?
One more.
Oh,
simply safe everybody.
You know,
thousands of people seeking home security get ripped off every day.
Isn't that ironic?
And the home security industry wants you to believe it's your only option.
They've got hoards of salesmen out there trying to scare you into signing one of
their longterm contracts.
You get stuck writing huge checks month after month with no way out.
Like that fucking movie,
that Stat Kevin Costner.
It's a robbery by contract and it can cost you thousands,
but there's a better way to protect your home.
Simply safe home security.
Simply faith has no contracts,
none.
You'll get award winning 24 seven protection named best in the industry now yet,
and they have a little award show.
Does Billy crystal come out and host it and do a little song and dance
beforehand?
Okay.
Security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police.
And I love that they're not the cops.
Oh my God,
something's,
I bet they still have the balls to have a fucking uniform too and it's just 1499
a month.
That's less than half of what companies charged.
Protect your home this mat way,
uh,
visit simply safe bird.com for an exclusive $10 off,
10% off.
This can't be fucking right.
That's their website and get a free key chain remote worth $25 only.
When you go to simply safe bird.com that's simply safe bird.com.
Evidently that's how he's saying.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you,
it does not sound right.
Um,
but whatever,
I don't write this shit.
Hey.
So I went out last night and I had a couple,
two,
three,
four,
five,
14 drinks last night and I was wearing my action slacks there.
And I gotta tell you,
I know this sounds like more advertising,
but a big fucking,
you know,
I tried to knock the head off my beer,
which I thought I did,
and then I looked down and it landed right on my leg and I went to shit.
It's gonna Stain.
I wiped it off and like
literally nothing happened was totally fine.
They like the greatest fucking pants I've ever had in my life,
but I look like a complete asshole with them,
you know?
But you know,
this is not how life is.
Isn't there always a price to pay?
Um,
all right,
so this is it.
This is my last fucking few hours here in Scotland.
And,
um,
two would not have had a better time,
but I am fucking ready to get out of this gloom and fucking doom of this God
damn place.
Holy Shit.
I mean,
it just feels like march.
It's August and it just feels like it's cold.
It's fucking rainy.
It's overcast.
Uh,
went to a couple of great bars last night was funny.
Talking to de Rosa draws us.
He's such a fucking animal,
you know.
He's like,
Hey,
let's go to the festival fucking bar.
It's like,
why the fuck would you want to go to the comedy festival thing?
We would,
they last night they're serving Guinness and Scotch and plastic cups.
You don't
have a little bit of respect for yourself.
Can we at least go to a place that has a,
has a glass,
you know,
so we ended up finding some bar.
MMM.
It was great.
You just,
can we just come walking in and there's these two guys sitting down.
One was playing the guitar,
the other guys playing the accordion,
this singing all these fucking songs.
It's tremendous,
right?
This is what kills me.
I apologize for making all you guys yarn.
I don't really apologize.
This fucking podcast is for free,
so I don't give a shit.
This is what kills me is I'm sitting at the bar and after about fucking a half
hour,
I find a look over it.
The fucking people,
uh,
with the guitar and the accordion and I look over now there's a woman sitting
there,
she's playing the fiddle and there's some other guys sitting down there and he's
playing the accordion.
I mean,
what are the odds of them?
What are the,
what are the odds that you're even going to walk into a bar and there's somebody
that,
that Ha Natalie has an accordion,
knows how to play it and a half hour later somebody else comes in.
Yeah.
And you can just hand it off to them.
Like it's a fucking guitar.
You know?
What is it a fucking squeezebox festival over here?
I've never seen that in my life.
Do you have any fucking bars?
I've gone to.
I don't either,
but it's a lot.
I've never seen anybody play an accordion and a bar in my life till I came to
Scotland.
I,
right.
It's fucking guys playing the shit out of it.
And then when I look over to go see the Eddie van Halen and fucking,
you know,
squeezebox is still playing.
It's,
it's somebody else.
But then again,
maybe he called up his friend.
Right.
And you know how plumbers though other plumbers,
right?
Hairdressers hanging out with hairdressers may be accordion players hang out
with each other.
I don't know.
It's kind
of a weird thing.
Right.
Do you think a
serial killer cell,
that's,
that's one that's very rare.
They don't hang out with each other.
You know,
it's just a quiet,
unspoken respect that they have with each other as they sit there on death row.
You know,
I wonder if that's a regret.
I should have hung out more with more complete fucking sociopath's.
If I could do it all over again,
you know,
I would have been part of a serial killer team,
so I could have shared those members with people.
Fucking,
that was really dark.
I apologize.
Um,
all right.
I think I gave you my half hour.
Yeah,
there we go.
Okay.
So,
um,
thank you for listening.
I am now my way to Germany and uh,
very excited.
Never been there before and I was just talking to a friend of mine has played
some gigs over there and said they're always fucking great crowds,
which makes sense,
you know,
it makes sense that they would be great crowds,
they got to make up for,
you know,
they're going to make up for it,
starting a couple of world wars,
right?
I was poor pastor,
so I'm going to give them shit today.
I'm going to give them shit.
I'm just going to be like,
you know,
you,
you fucking guys,
all your contributions that you've made,
you know,
from audio tape to some of the greatest automobiles people have ever seen.
And it's just,
it's just a goddamn shame that
no one's ever going to think of that first because you picked one Ron guy,
that's all.
They didn't show me.
They just,
they picked one wrong guy and it just turned out to be the biggest fucking
lunatic in modern history.
Somebody had to pick up.
You know,
this is a thing too,
as Trump is doing what he's still wanted.
People like,
if people try to compare Trump to Hitler,
you know what I mean?
Let me give me a fucking break.
He's nowhere near and Hitler's league,
right?
Hitler used to crush those speeches.
Donald Trump is just rumbling,
bumbling,
stumbling.
You know what I mean?
His whole campaign has just been like a fucking Hail Mary and went up in the air
and everybody's going knock.
Yeah,
Dow,
knock it down.
Right.
What happened?
Or lack it goes up and he tries to catch the fucking thing.
It's someone slaps it out of his hand and then landed.
It's,
I dunno,
landed in Hillary Clinton's fucking cleavage.
And now these are the two clowns we've got to look at.
Tell you it's a rough one.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll,
uh,
have a wonderful weekend.
You and I'll check in on you.
MMM,
no,
I'm checking in on you now.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Right?
Okay.
Abraham,
kill me a son.
Say,
man,
you must be putting me on.
No,
I say you can do what you want him.
Next time you see me coming,
you better run.
Where do you want this?
God Six.
There was
Georgia,
Sam,
he did a bloody nose
and get him.
No clue.
Can I go?
That is all in one place.
I know Sam,
Sam,
tell man quick man,
I got to run
with his gun is way down.
Highway 61.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 11th.
And uh,
this week I am going to be at the Improv in Miami,
Florida on uh,
August 14th.
That's Thursday through Sunday.
August 17th.
And I'm one of those days I'm going to a Florida Marlin's game,
the Mylans as they say back in Boston.
And um,
that is the last professional baseball team franchise that I need to see.
And then I have seen all of them.
And,
uh,
it was something that,
you know,
as I've been on the road over the years,
I always wanted to go to every baseball stadium and,
uh,
I will have accomplished it this week and got to admit it's kind of an empty
feeling,
you know what I mean?
Because it's not the goal.
It's more the journey,
you know,
you don't really think it is really,
it's the fact that I went to all of them by myself.
I think that that's what it has to do with actually the last third I started
going with other people,
but I have pictures of me in front of every major sports stadium that you can
think of.
God dammit,
that exists or doesn't exist anymore because they've torn down so many of them
since I'd been on the road.
Um,
I have like a certain level of OCD where I get in.
It's not like I open and close the fucking door 58 times as,
um,
you know,
counting up to 100 by odd numbers,
which I guess is in Paul hundred and one by odd numbers.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't have kind of shit.
I just have like I get into shit and when I get into what,
I just get psycho into it and it lasts for about a month and a half and then I
just don't give a shit about it anymore.
And that probably explains why I haven't been able to sustain a relationship in
my life.
Um,
it's a whole nother story,
but no,
it's something that I did when I went on the road because going on the road
sucks.
But I remember as a kid when I used to watch before there was ever even sports
center,
let's go back here,
go back in the day for all you youngsters out there who enjoy,
you know,
five or six different 24 hour sports channels.
Um,
back in the day they didn't,
they didn't have shit like that.
They sports used to come on,
you'd get the local sports guy in my neck of the woods.
It was Bob Lowe Bell and the guy would come on,
you know,
six o'clock news.
He would come on at about six 36 35 and if you were lucky,
you'd get six,
seven minutes of sports.
You know what I mean?
And that'd be,
you know,
whatever the greatest play around the league was,
you'd get that and then maybe you'd get a whatever your closest rival was doing,
but it was very quick and it was very local.
It was definitely just mostly about your team and how your team fit into the
overall scheme of stuff.
And uh,
but I remember he used to watch this week in baseball.
He used to come on once a week with,
with Mel Allen and it,
well how's that sound?
Was like been done,
done,
done.
Bought up a Ba Ba ba Ba ba Ba.
And I'd be sitting in my pajamas watching the fucking show,
you know,
I get chills.
Sports were bigger than life back then cause I was a little kid and they also
didn't come on all the time.
You know what I mean?
They didn't,
back in the day,
if Manny Ramirez went from the fucking red sox to the Dodgers,
that would be,
it'd be in the paper for a day or two maybe locally,
but around the all whole league of be there once to just be an MP.
Just a blurb,
American league,
slugger,
Manny Ramirez,
attention,
ladies and gentlemen,
all the ships and say they would just be a quick little thing and that would be,
it wouldn't be up his ass every five seconds,
measuring the length of his dreadlocks the way they do now.
So,
um,
that's the thing.
So I don't know,
as a kid,
I always wanted to go to,
uh,
I used to think about that.
How cool would it be to go to the different stadiums?
So when I went on the road,
it dawned on me one day,
I don't know where the fuck I was at,
maybe I was in Seattle and I was like,
you know what,
the fucking kingdom,
Seattle Mariners,
Seattle Seahawks,
that bald guy who paints his head,
like the helmet,
that fucking place is right down the street.
And I would just,
uh,
if I had time,
I would go to a game.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I just started doing it.
Then I just started scheduling my road gigs around it.
And this is how my OCD kicked in.
It was like,
you know what,
I'd like to go to all the great baseball stadiums.
Started off with that.
I'll go to fucking,
you know,
Fenway,
which I've where I'm from,
Yankee stadium,
Wrigley,
Camden yards,
blah,
blah.
And then it became,
ah,
I'm gonna go,
I'm gonna know every baseball stadium.
Right?
And then my OCD was like,
well,
I don't,
well what about footfall?
I'm like,
I'll go to all the football.
Then it became all the hockey,
then it became,
I am going to go to every fucking stadium in all four professional sports.
Okay.
And I'd be on the plane like rain man writing down and those little cocktail
napkins that you get from the stewardesses,
right.
And I would be writing down how many I had and which divisions,
like,
like a fucking psycho.
And it was something that totally appealed to my brain and made the flight go by
quicker.
So a long story short,
I believe I used to know this shit because I kind of stopped giving a fuck.
You don't.
It was when I went to a golden state warriors game by myself when they socked.
And I was holding their free go warriors sign.
That's when I knew right then and there,
I think I have that picture on my website to build [inaudible] dot com and I
think I wrote underneath,
it's something about,
that's when I realized that I had a problem or I was sick,
but um,
I don't know.
It's like 122 teams or something.
They might have added a few since I last did the Raymond thing,
but I have been to
I think like 85
85.
Can you fucking believe that by myself for the most part,
like 72 of those I went by myself and um,
this is the last baseball one and then I can basically check baseball off other
than a few new stadiums that they,
that they made.
I haven't been in the new Philly one.
I haven't been to the new Padres one,
but other than that,
I've been to all of them,
which is pretty fucking cool,
but also pathetic and sad on some level.
Um,
but I literally just forgot my whole fucking train of thought there.
That was such a long goddamn story.
Oh,
I know.
So last one I'm going to go down into is this fucking the Marlins one and it's
going to be a day game in fucking Miami.
So it'll be like nine zillion degrees out and uh,
then we'll be done with baseball then.
You know what?
Then I'm not going to know what the fuck to do with myself.
That's the empty feeling.
I'm not going to know what to do with myself when I go on the road and uh,
and it's the summertime.
What the fuck am I going to do?
What am I going to do to kill a day?
Go to a museum.
You know,
something.
This would actually be fucking interesting if I actually took pictures of all
this shit.
I can make a great coffee book,
Coffee Table Book of all the Shit I've done by myself.
The space needle,
I didn't do it by myself.
Oh,
I did.
I,
yes I did.
I went up that by myself.
And another time I was doing a college gig with Ben Bailey.
Oh,
we didn't go up in it.
He just wanted me to take a picture of him with that thing in the background
I think.
Right.
Jesus Christ.
I'm this,
this,
this podcast is really depressing.
The Shit on me.
Let's bring up some good memories because you're probably thinking right now,
if you're a baseball fan,
you probably like bill,
what were your favorite fucking state of best?
One I went to was a,
the old tiger stadium.
Um,
cause we have that upper deck that went around the entire,
the entire field.
And I remember I went to a game,
it was an inner league game against the pirates and it was dusk and it
literally,
I don't know why it looked like it was 1907 when you were in there and you
literally thought ty Cobb
would come running out on the field screaming a bunch of racist shit or whatever
the fuck they say about him.
The hard drinking racist,
he'd sharpen the spikes in carnival that,
that guys in the hall of fame and Pete Rose's.
And although I understand it on a level,
you know what I mean?
Because what Pete rose did actually I would say affected the entire integrity of
the game.
He could have brought everybody down,
but you know,
you know what the bottom line is?
I mean,
they just busted a rough word,
mob ties and the fucking NBA,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
we're still watching hoop and people are still gambling on it.
You know why?
Because we have fucking nothing better to do.
All right.
That was a long ass fucking story.
Um,
I hope it was remotely interesting.
Ah,
let's get it onto the podcast.
Questions here.
Uh,
question number one,
Bill,
if you,
Lisa,
some brutal questions this week,
by the way.
I think all the superficial ones are over and you guys are going from Merrill.
So listen to these fucking questions and if you knew to my page,
okay,
if you are new to my page,
you know,
if you haven't gone over to,
uh,
to Facebook,
you know what I mean?
Does anybody else feel like when you're in my space,
like you're,
you're,
you're in like a failing restaurant.
You know what I mean?
That's what I feel like I'm just staring across them all at the newer,
shiny or one,
you know,
I got my apron around my waist,
my wife,
my fantasy wife comes up to me.
Just go on.
It's okay if people will come back,
you know,
we've been down before.
We could get through anything as long as you are me and I love you,
God damn cough ruin that Improv.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Question number one.
If you had to choose between losing your ability to perform standup slash being
funny,
meaning you'll never perform again.
Never be on radio,
a radio show.
This dude even took radio out of the picture and I'd have to go work at a normal
job in quotes or lose the ability to get an erection.
What would you pick?
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Yeah,
and in my life on both of them,
but
after a long painful thought,
ah,
I had to go to
either one that I picked.
My life is over and it's going to ruin the enjoyment of the other thing.
You know what I mean?
Like if,
if I can still get an erection now,
I'm just not a comedian anymore.
And then,
then,
then you say,
I have to go work a normal job.
First of all,
do it.
I've been doing standup for 16 years.
That's kind of a huge gap to have in your resume.
All right,
I have a communications degree and you're taking my ability to do radio off the
fucking table.
So,
uh,
basically
my option is to go wash dishes in a restaurant and try to fuck every waitress
who works there or continue living my dream as a comedian.
You know what?
I'd have to,
I'd have to choose losing the ability to get an erection.
Can I take Viagara Bob Dole can't get an erection.
And I know he was real happy when that shit came out,
I guess.
Is that cheating?
Um,
now because you know what?
I have a chance to make
my mark as a comedian because it's something I'm really good at and I can
actually somehow work my way
up the ladder and at least feel like I achieved something.
And,
uh,
I mean,
what am I going to get into the,
the,
the pussy fucking all time pussy getting guys,
you know what I do at this point,
you know,
I mean,
ah,
Jesus Christ.
You,
you're an asshole.
Whoever wrote that you were an asshole.
It's a great fucking question.
Jesus Christ.
Would I be funny if I couldn't fuck anymore?
Holy Shit.
The pent up energy,
I'd be like 80 years old still jumping around like fucking Brian Regan.
They'd be like,
I don't know.
He does it.
He,
he never lost the fire.
I'll tie.
Did I fucking did it?
I couldn't.
I hadn't been able to fuck this.
I was 40.
How about that?
All right,
question number two.
Uh,
okay,
so you didn't get to this one last time.
So let's see if you do this time around most humiliating medical experience.
What do you think?
Jock itch or a colonoscopy,
however the fuck you say it.
A colonoscopy without a doubt.
You know what I mean?
A jock itch.
I believe that's over the counter.
You just have to subtly walk down that aisle at the pharmacy and act like you're
looking for diet coke.
You know Jock Itch,
isn't that right?
Next to athlete's foot,
you just walked down the itchy aisle.
What would happen if you put the athlete's foot stuff
in your job?
What is jock itch junkets basically.
It doesn't mean you sweat your balls off.
You don't change your underwear.
First of all were boxers.
Okay.
Creates a little more ventilation.
You don't keep everything,
all that.
It's just disgusting.
That's fucking gross.
Jesus Christ.
One painful question.
One one disgusting one.
Alright.
Colonoscopy.
Yeah.
I don't want to do that.
I don't want it.
No,
I don't want to do that.
First of all,
because they're going to be able to figure out a way that to look in your ass
without going into your ass.
I'm holding out for that.
I've seen some stories on the news about it.
Nobody's entering my ass.
I don't.
Okay.
I don't give a shit if he got the fucking lab coat on or any of that crap.
I'm not doing it.
I'm not.
No.
Fuck you.
And I'm looking in there.
Yeah.
You're going to find something the same way.
I mean,
I'm fucking 40 years old.
You're going to find something.
I'd be like,
if you had an old car,
somebody starts fucking,
you know,
looking down in the Pistons,
you're going to find something down there.
Know we need to do,
yeah,
nothing.
That's what we need to do.
You asshole.
Stop trying to make a mortgage payment with my anus.
All right.
Oh Jesus.
Sorry.
I'm still a little fucking sick here.
All right,
number three,
bill,
have you ever had a problem with the girlfriend getting mad at you that you
whack off to porn?
You know,
whack off is one of the worst ways of putting it.
that really just makes me seem pathetic.
Like I'm just slamming,
slamming it against the inside of my leg.
Um,
and this guy says,
I don't girls who say that they consider it cheating and I think that's bullshit
because?
Because it's not real and you just rub one out with a visual aid.
I just don't think fantasy shit should be outlawed just because you're in a
relationship.
What do you think?
Well,
I admit that it isn't cheating because cheating,
um,
you know,
she ain't,
you got to be somehow with another live human being.
Okay.
And,
um,
no matter how enjoyable,
uh,
I almost said whacking off like you fucking rubber one out to porn can be,
but it's still something pathetic about it,
you know?
And that's that feeling of guilt afterwards where you think it's your parent.
If you know something your parents said or maybe your church,
but it isn't,
it's the patheticness that's your male DNA going.
You know,
you couldn't find somebody alive to do this with,
you know what I mean?
You're useless.
You're not a hunter.
You're a gatherer.
And why don't you go out in the kitchen and go eat some berries?
You fucking pussy.
Um,
no,
I don't think it's cheating,
but I don't think you should do it,
uh,
with your girlfriend one about it.
Unless she's into it.
You know,
how creepy would that be?
Well,
she,
she's like one of those creepy fucking dudes.
If you see those dudes who like want to see somebody banged their wife and they
just sit there peak in and while you're doing it,
you know,
you haven't seen those videos.
It's fucking creepy things with the girlfriend was like that on to Pekin.
I'm literally losing every female in the podcast right now.
They're all going
tot up.
All right.
Um,
yeah,
I don't think it's cheating,
but uh,
I also,
you know,
I'm really anti porn.
I just don't think it's good.
I just talk about that on stage.
This is how I view,
I feel like,
I think your soul is like pixelated and every time you look at some shit that
you shouldn't,
this shouldn't be looking at a couple of cubes,
just float away and,
and you never get them back.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like that back to the future,
you know,
we start to fade away except it's your soul,
she's probably slipped the fuck am I talking about?
All right,
here's somebody,
um,
starts off,
it says my best question yet.
We'll give this guy patting himself on the back.
How do or how,
uh,
how do you feel about potentially hurting slash embarrassing your family?
I think they mean with,
uh,
with some of your material.
Um,
yeah,
I'm definitely conscious of that.
That's why,
you know,
I usually just tell over the top stories and,
uh,
I try not to make anybody look too,
too bad.
I toned everything down,
but I'm definitely conscious of that.
So,
yeah.
How I feel about that,
I feel like I don't want to embarrass them.
Um,
question number five,
what is your favorite Olympic event to watch?
And by the way,
phone,
sex is the cure for AIDS is my new myspace quote.
Um,
oh,
thank you.
I'm glad you and Julie one on,
let's see.
What is your favorite Olympic events?
We'll watch Jesus Christ.
Uh,
what is it?
Um,
I like the 100 meter dash,
the one that Ben Johnson and Carl Lewis did.
I liked that one.
The fastest fuckers on the earth.
I don't mind the swimming.
I actually like the volleyball,
especially female volleyball,
you know,
I dunno.
Volleyball makes girls,
the thighs are all sick.
They'll get booties anyway.
Those fucking,
uh,
sergeant slaughter onesies.
Um,
the boxing,
I like a lot of this shit to downhill skiing.
I like,
I actually like a lot of the events,
the hockeys great.
Jesus Christ and I have the basketball.
I haven't watched any of them.
I don't know why.
I haven't watched any of it.
I just realized I really liked the Olympics.
Um,
I'm hoping there's some point they come back to La and then when the coliseum
right down the fucking street,
wouldn't that be great?
Uh,
uh,
all the way I see USC Trojan saw.
How the fuck does the Olympic Song,
wait,
I'm hearing it then.
Wow.
I can only hear the first note.
I'd suck on that name.
That tune show.
How does it go now?
I've got the Trojan Song in my head.
Don't you fucking hate when you do it?
Wait a minute.
Oh,
it's fucking,
that's the graduation song.
Fuck.
Does he Olympic Song Go.
You know what?
If anybody can email me writing like almost like,
yeah,
fucking email Morse code.
You know,
anything that that's stressed.
He just capitalize
the,
the DA,
Da,
dat,
dat that,
that,
uh,
that that's it right there.
Just had to think of fucking Jim Mckay able to see blah,
blah blah before,
um,
all right.
And with that we are now into last week I was sick and uh,
what do you guys want to hear first?
You want to hear,
uh,
we'll close with underrated.
Overrated,
which is a topic that's really been taken off.
So if he hadn't been listening,
people have been sending into the,
in their list of shit that they think is overrated and underrated and a very
passionate subject because you know how it is you watching TV and there'll be
somebody who you think is,
is who is great and they're not on TV or you think a band is cool and no one's
listening to them.
And then there's something that everybody's into and you just think it
absolutely sucks and it drives you nuts.
After a while you start walking around talking to himself.
And that's how I think that's why the a,
the overrated or underrated list have taken off.
But before we get into that,
for those of you like myself who don't like getting cold,
here are some people's cold remedies.
All right,
Skye,
number one.
Uh,
I see you got a cold,
aren't you perceptive?
Um,
he said,
here's a rough recipe to handle that cold.
And this is what I love about this fucking email.
This is a recipe and he gives me no measurements whatsoever.
All right?
Hey,
here's the recipe.
It's beef or can be chicken.
Caltough a k a soup.
So it's beef Caldo or chicken Caldo or I guess soup,
okay?
I Dunno what the fuck cal domains,
but he says,
also known as soup,
like a committed a crime.
It needs an alias,
okay?
You make,
you make this,
you'll be straightened two days Max.
This is what always happens when you have a cold.
People come up to you,
you got to call bird.
All you gotta do is this,
man.
I'm telling you,
I do it all the time and every get a fucking call and three weeks later you see
the guy,
he's got to fucking call and you're like,
dude,
what happened?
Uh Oh dude.
You know,
the show didn't make the stuff well,
why didn't you make the stuff?
If it's,
uh,
if,
if it automatically makes you not get a cold,
he fuckin ass all.
First of all,
nobody knows how to cure the common cold.
If you did,
you'd release it onto the market and you'd make a zillion dollars like that.
Chica did the airborne thing,
but this guy,
evidently he's giving this thing away for free and be very cynical here and I
apologize.
All right,
here you go.
And uh,
you'll be straight and to treat A's Max.
All right.
Um,
[inaudible] he also said trash the tree that the t you got to,
you need to get that cinnamon apple t the celestial shit with the lady in the
front.
Yeah,
that's exactly how it went to the store.
You got that cinnamon apple tea.
You know the [inaudible] seal shit with the,
with the lady in the front there.
Could you please not use that language in the store?
Okay.
And it's a woman,
not a lady.
Okay.
We've progressed this weekend phone,
I'll fuck you.
You con security.
All right.
Anyways,
you eat that stuff up.
Sugar.
I'm okay.
Here are the ingredients for the soup ingredients.
Chicken or beef,
carrots,
cabbage,
corn,
potatoes and Jalapeno pepper.
That's capitalized.
Not that can shit,
but the raw stuff,
the stuff they pull out of the ground.
Get that peppers green in the soup.
I don't know what it is,
but it helps for real.
Oh,
but it helps for real son.
Anytime I'm sick,
if I have even feel something coming,
Bam.
Capital letters make some Colorado and it's over and done.
All right,
so maybe it doesn't matter.
Maybe you just take some beef or chicken stock.
Is that what you're saying?
And I throw some carrots in there.
I feel like bugs bunny or fucking curly on three stooges.
I just throw the shit in.
They're going on.
They just fucking throw in there.
Alright.
Compliment the soup was some corn tortillas too.
Hey,
if there's any Latino people listening to this,
can you please explain to me all that shit?
I get all that shit confused.
It's like I am anxiety when I go into a Mexican restaurant cause all I know it
Tacos and Burritos and when he get into tortillas and I chat at OPA and
Gorditos,
I don't know what the fuck it is and I don't even know if it even is authentic
at this point because basically my education on Mexican food is Taco bell
commercials and I know that's white people doing it.
So,
and they're just making up shit.
You know what I mean?
They put extra layers of cheese in it.
Uh,
what is a Tortilla?
Is that one of those round things
that you fold up and it becomes a Burrito?
I Dunno,
but anyways,
this guy says hazard was having with some Limonada.
Is that,
is this kind of Latin,
is that like fucking Mexican for lemonade or is there actually something called,
oh,
Limonata l I m o n a Da and put some garlic salt in there too.
Also heat the meet up first then dumped the water.
Do you know what this fucking recipe doesn't even make sense?
You'd be the worst fucking shift
on the food network.
You've got it all.
You know this,
there's no amounts getting it right in a dasher garlic salt and it puts some
fucking garlic salt in there too.
Okay,
I'll do that.
All right.
Number two is if somebody else's,
I'm actually getting stuffed up as I'm talking about this lead here in the bed.
Okay.
Number two.
Um,
okay.
You've been sick on your podcast at least three times before.
I think you get sick about every six months.
Ha Ha.
There are signs the body gives that you should start to recognize before he get
fully sick.
The first side you get.
Take something for God's sake.
Ha Express is calling me a fucking idiot.
Um,
I keep a bottle of Tylenol extra strength.
As soon as I feel a little different,
I take two.
What?
I'm cool in the morning.
Try it.
I'm sure you'll get sick before Christmas.
Let me know if it works.
All right.
Why am I getting all fucking stuffed up now?
Number three,
take new snacks for the kids.
For the congestion.
The stuff is money for colds,
you know,
at this is just all over the counter shit.
You know what I mean?
I want,
I wanted like somebody secret grandparent were fucking recipe like that guy
above me.
Maybe that's why he didn't give me any sort of a,
he didn't give me any sort of fucking measurements.
He's protecting the recipe.
All right,
here's one for garlic.
Last week I was telling you how people say that garlic works.
Here's a guy who claims he never gets sick.
He says,
first of all,
uh,
I used to get back in the day I was a fucking health wreck.
I used to get colds at least once,
twice a month.
But today I haven't had a cold in about two years.
Now the secret is garlic.
Whenever I feel like I'm catching a cold,
I eat two to four garlic cloves.
I don't mash them up our slice them or anything else.
Pussy like sky's very judgmental.
All right.
And I just cut them up in two or three pieces and pop them like pills along with
a shitload of water.
And then of course I brushed my teeth.
Um,
Hey,
who?
I know that it might sound somewhat off putting and somewhat off putting and
maybe a tad bit disgusting,
but dude,
it's fucking worth it.
You know what?
I'm going to try that.
I always go with the natural shit or whatever.
I always go with however we originally did it because I just have a feeling that
everything else is just fucking an evil way of making money.
You know what I mean?
Don't listen to me.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about that that would rule out penicillin which
has saved people's lives and add it to the population problem.
And
you know what I mean?
That's why everyone in China rides a bike.
Not because they can't afford a car,
they just,
you wouldn't get anywhere.
Um,
and then that's not even sure.
They don't all ride bikes and just made that up cause I was trying to get onto
the overrated,
underrated,
the new hot topic here on,
uh,
on my podcast.
Jesus Christ.
I'm running out of energy here.
I still have lingering effects from that fucking super cold.
I called last week.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated.
And then I'm going to get the fuck outta here.
Okay.
And once again,
people just let you know.
I do have my,
uh,
my one hour special coming up as you can see the banner at the top of the page
and I look at me looking to the side like,
wow,
I really do have a special August 31st.
Okay.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Um,
let's see.
Fucking okay.
Overrated.
Hang on,
let me get to it.
Let me get to it.
Here's something that I,
that is overrated and not living up to the hype tattoos.
Everyone in their fucking grandmother have the God Damn Tattoo and it's
completely ruined the outlaw rebel status at once,
at once.
Had,
you know what?
I got to agree with that.
That's who you used to mean you are a bad ass.
You know what I mean?
As a guy,
you know what I mean?
That you could walk into a bar and if someone fucked with you,
you'd knocked her ass out.
And as a woman it used to mean you bet aware.
Two condoms because I have fucked a lot of guys.
That's what it used to mean.
Now it just means you're a follower.
You know what I like?
I like the people who would have been the people who just got tattoos,
but now they have to take it to the next level and they're doing that thing
where they're
trying to turn their fucking ear lobes into a gymnastic rings.
I really don't understand that at all.
That it is the most fucking disgusting thing.
People getting tattoos on their faces now,
like that rapid,
they're out of Atlanta,
young wheezy,
wherever he is from.
He turned me on to that guy recently.
I actually think he's fucking funny as hell,
but the tattoos or re I was actually joking with somebody.
You know what?
That guy has tattoos look like.
He looks like he walked into a tattoo parlor and looked at the wall and goes,
yeah,
let me get all that.
Just give me a tattoo of your wall.
You know what I mean?
There's just no rhyme or reason to it.
Every once in a while you'll,
you'll see like a really cool tattoo,
like a,
I saw this girl in Denver.
She had a,
and I didn't even want to say this because then I think someone else is going to
do it and then it's going to,
these tattoos will become like the hacky barbed wire tattoo.
This girl just had a tattoo of a bunch of different like pinup girls from the
1940s and that's all they were.
She'd have like 100 a forearm,
one on the inside,
one of the top one,
the uh,
biceps.
So it was kind of like bond,
Scott's tattoos,
the old,
the original singer of AC DC.
We just had like a fucking eagle or a dragon on his forearm and you looked at
it,
you could see what it was and to look cool wasn't like those,
you know,
those sleeves that people get like Tommy Lee where it just looks like a scribble
pad.
They'll sing her the fucking worst.
You can't see anything.
I don't know.
All right.
So I guess I'm agreeing with you.
I think if you get like a one really cool personal tattoo and also you keep
yourself in shape,
uh,
the tattoo can still look cool,
but you definitely have to take some sort of Jujitsu at that point to make you
worthy of having the fucking tattoo or at the very least committed a felony,
you know.
Anyways,
some of the other overhead stuff,
the Hummer h three celebrities and shopping.
All right.
Something I don't get,
uh,
the douchey trend of those tee shirts that say famous.
What kind of tool where something like that.
I don't know if I've seen those.
That's one of those things I don't think I've seen about.
I know you're talking about,
that's Kinda like the loser tee shirt is another one.
People that liked the rascal flats or Kenny Chesney,
I dunno who the rascal Flatts are.
Kenny Chesney,
is he the guy who married that,
that um,
that chick from Jerry Maguire,
what the fuck is her name?
All I can think of is an Haitian,
that's the first name that popped in my head,
but I know it's not her.
Um,
the diary of,
of
uh,
what is that fucking girl?
You know the girl I'm talking about,
I'm in that country style.
You always want,
I knew about the guy cause I can't stand country music.
I don't mind some of the oldest shit from the 50s,
early sixties,
but country music today.
It's socks.
All right.
It's just beyond corny.
Oh my God.
Somebody who was playing Garth Brooks the other day,
that guy fucking blows.
I hate how they,
like they always start every line way down low and then they moved their way up.
Oh God.
Kill yourself.
Fucking kill yourself.
Country Music socks.
You know,
I wouldn't,
I,
that's the only genre of music that I can just say that unequivocally straight
across the board.
It just sucks.
It always sounds like a bunch of fucking corn balls who think they're cool and
that line dancing,
we do that stupid shit.
We,
uh,
lift your leg up and you whack the arch of your fucking cowboy boot and then the
whack the other side of it.
Terrible.
Absolutely terrible.
Um,
and I also don't like how they all have to act like they're so fucking pure.
You know what I mean?
Like they're not getting groupie pussy,
you know,
and then they write all those patriotic songs,
cashing in,
you know,
America is going to go blow you up and all that shit.
That was one of the greatest parties ever.
Do you guys ever see that fucking those guys from South Park?
That was my favorite part of that movie where they did the movie with the
Marionette puppet puppets there and they did the,
uh,
they did that song.
What would you day he had gave your lap of freedom.
What would you do?
I was such a subtle,
wonderful slam on people who made those songs.
Anyways.
Um,
all right,
another overrated thing.
Guitar Hero.
Thank you.
Bunch of fucking nerves.
That's another great south park episode.
South park is fucking genius,
by the way.
If you're not watching it,
if they're still making genius episodes and no one ever talks about it anymore.
MTVS overrated.
Yeah.
MTV They faced,
they've sucked for 20 years now.
Reality shows.
I don't think that those things are overrated.
I got to argue on that one.
People know there's shitty shows,
you know?
It's kind of like the Jonas brothers.
People just know that that sucks,
but there's morons and they're into it.
A Metallica is overrated.
In the eighties early nineties they kicked ass,
but nowadays,
no.
Wow.
Packing a legend there.
A Hannah Montana.
How can she be overrated?
She's not overrated.
She's like a,
what do you walk up to an 11 year old and make her cry about her lunchbox.
This person's really mean.
All right,
everybody.
You see in every week's issue of every single entertainment magazine,
examples,
Brad Pitt,
Angelina Jolie,
Lindsay Lohan,
Britney spears,
Miley Cyrus,
delos magazines.
So seeing the magazines sucker,
right?
Brad Pitt was also in snatched.
He was also in fight club.
He's made some good movies.
He played the fucking,
the pothead and a true romance.
I don't think he's overrated.
I just think he's better looking at me.
He gets,
you know,
painless pussy.
All right,
underrated.
I think I literally caught a cold again during this fucking podcast.
This is really long by the way.
I'm sorry guys.
Let me just,
this is the end right here under it.
Something else that is,
uh,
I'll wait somehow.
I got this in the yoga.
This is another overrated.
The iPod.
Oh,
I liked this one.
This guy said the iPod is overrated.
I don't like it.
I'm sure it's a wonderful toy,
but honestly everyone I know who has one has something bad to say about it.
Whether it's shits the bed or only plays part of a song.
I Dunno.
I'm just a guy who goes against the pop culture bullshit.
No,
I would say the Ipod is the Ipod,
like,
uh,
if he can't get them fixed either,
you know what I mean?
Like you stereo back in the day when you had a record player,
it didn't like become obsolete six months later.
You know what I mean?
And your friend would get a new record player and they could play way more
records.
It's bullshit.
Yeah.
I don't,
I actually lost my iPod about two years ago.
I haven't had an iPod in two years.
And,
uh,
I don't give a fuck because,
you know,
they're fucking expensive and you'll lose them and they break easily.
Exactly.
The back of them is made out of the same material.
Like if he'd make like a cheap toaster or something,
you know what I mean?
It's made out of aluminum and evidently the disk that spins a shit in there,
whatever the fuck it is,
is right behind it.
And if you dent that,
it rubs up against it.
And that's what fucks it up.
And,
uh,
I love that too.
When you go in the iPod store and then they're just like,
um,
have you ever dropped your iPod?
No.
Never.
There's no gravity in my apartment.
You fucking asshole.
Yes,
I did.
Let me get,
that's not covered.
You don't cover gravity.
All right.
Um,
underrated things around in a rated good books,
music,
movies and art.
Uh,
I would definitely say good books are,
I don't think music's underrated.
I think people across the board,
like music,
movies aren't,
I guess,
you know,
people,
good,
good music.
You mean movies are going to a museum.
I love this one.
Underrated.
Kenny Rogers roasters.
That place was good,
awesome chicken.
You know what I ate there.
It wasn't bad.
It was comparable to pop eyes.
Is there a clean Popeye's in the world,
by the way?
Every time you walk in there,
the biscuits on the ship.
But those are the dirtiest fucking restaurants ever.
All right.
Backer was underrated.
Hilarious Sitcom that ran from 1998 to 2004 on cvs starring Ted Danson.
Um,
that's show sucked.
I didn't like it.
I didn't buy Ted Beck dance and be an angry,
you know why he couldn't play angry?
Because he was already on a show that made syndication,
you know,
and now he was alright.
And then he was on another one that made syndication.
So he had so much fucking money.
How can you be angry?
It's like ice cube.
I just don't buy the anger anymore.
He's got another album coming out and shit.
It's just like,
how are you still mad,
dude?
Okay.
Even making platinum albums for 20 fucking years,
you seamlessly stepped into movies starring in them.
Okay.
And now you're making your own.
I mean,
he's got to have like fucking,
he's got to be worth half a billion dollars at this point.
He still has that scowl on his face.
His eyebrows really annoy me.
They're always touching whenever he delivers his shit.
You know what I mean?
You're not that angry ice.
All right?
Did I just say ice?
Like I knew him.
Like I say his whole name.
You're not that angry as Cuban not buying it.
Right.
You fucking 48 years old.
All right.
Okay.
Rush.
This person said is underrated.
One of the greatest rock bands,
to be honest,
they have been a band for 34 years and still not inducted into the rock and roll
hall of fame.
It's bullshit.
No,
it isn't.
It's not bullshit.
Rush socks.
That band sucks.
Okay.
Musically,
technically what they're doing is incredible,
but the songs stink.
And Getty Lee's voice is annoying and I just find they're playing to be real
robotic.
There's no feeling in it
today.
[inaudible] I
got Byron and right on the beat,
they're not pushing it.
And I laid back are literally right on it,
like a fucking drum machine,
uh,
to fucking thumbs down.
And Getty Lee just seems like somebody you'd want to grab by his ponytail and
just spin them over your head like a fucking helicopter.
Uh,
all right,
last one.
Dirty work.
The movie dirty work.
It's a hilarious movie starring Norm Macdonald and Artie Lange and was produced
by Bob Saget.
Um,
you know what,
the trailers or that movie looks funny.
I might rent that.
And speaking of that,
if you want to watch one of the fucking most jaw droppingly awful movies of all
time,
and I'm going to end on this.
I actually finally watched the movie neighbors starring John Belushi and Dan
Akroyd.
It is without a doubt,
one of the biggest pieces of shit that I have ever seen in my life.
And uh,
I remember the big thing about that movie was John Belushi was playing the nerd
and Akroyd was playing the crazy guy.
And I dunno,
I think they were so nervous that people at the time would not accept John
Belushi as the nerdy guy,
that every time they showed his character to reinforce that he was a nerdy
character is if I couldn't tell on my own,
they would play like this.
You know,
trombone like this loser.
Every time they showed his character,
it's like,
dude,
I got it.
He's the fucking loser.
But I'll tell you,
the movie makes absolutely no sense.
And it just,
it just ends on just some dumb joke and it doesn't,
it doesn't like remember in an apocalypse now when Marlon Brando's character
talks about seeing the inoculated stack of arms and saying he wanted to pull his
teeth out,
that's what that movie made me want to do.
Like literally my teeth hurt.
It was such a bad fucking movie.
All right,
this fucking podcast is way too God damn long.
Um,
and you know why it's so long now.
It's because everybody's throwing on giving me all this great stuff,
all this feedback,
you know,
so I appreciate all that type of stuff.
Uh,
maybe I'll just try to start picking the top ones.
I just feel like I got to read all of them because people take the time to send
them in.
But I think I just did like a 40 minute podcast.
Um,
I don't want to get somebody fired out there if you actually listen to this in
your cubicle.
Um,
so anyways,
that's it.
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
once again,
I'm going to be at the Improv,
Miami,
Florida,
and I will be whatever the day game is at the Marlin's.
I'm going to be at that game.
Okay.
And then only be 500 people there,
so I'll be easy to find.
So if you there,
please say hello and come on down to the Improv on the 14th through the 17th.
I'll be down there.
Please look for my special August 31st on comedy central and that is it.
And I really appreciate all the feedback and everybody's been giving me the
podcast questions.
Please keep them coming.
Even if they're painful,
they're fucking great and a underrated overrated.
I'll let shit.
Alright,
that is it.
Uh,
I hope all you guys have a good week.
I'll talk to you next Monday.
12th may tell them
things
she says in as much do you weigh?
He said,
come here and staffing
limit.
Tell a second mother.
This has been
done
since day one.
Okay.
He was bad.
Next.
Whoa,
whoa,
Bro.
Modo who nearly fell off the floor,
he said never engaged in this kind of thing.
They fall by body.
Yes.
I think it can be a very easy,
we'll is
put some bleach us out in us.